you've been together with your wife for
seven years uh what what's some advice
you'd give to
you know people to kind of have a
successful relationship because that's a
long time to be with anybody bro
no cap it's it's it's hard and that's
the first thing i want
everybody who's looking for love to
understand it's hard as [ __ ]
yeah you don't get nobody and it's
easier it gets harder so you guys
understand how to [ __ ] to deal with each
other
we lived together before we got married
so we knew exactly what we were getting
into right people don't even want to go
through the journey
but they're so quick to fall in love you
don't even know the [ __ ] you
with but you love them you posted them
on your instagram your social media
y'all know each other's passwords you
knew each other for two months what's
crazy [ __ ] is happening that's crazy
like what happened to the talking phase
yeah it's like crazy no calm a [ __ ] no
i love [ __ ] like like the next [ __ ]
don't get me wrong you feel me
but what i'm saying what happened to the
talking stage right
no full disclosure every hood [ __ ] you
might laugh me after this my wife didn't
let me [ __ ] for three months 90 days
no [ __ ] and i stuck around mm-hmm
took on
dates rubbed that [ __ ] feet
showed up we ate dinner together no we
did it
hey loki i did the same thing with my
wife bro it's fire i'ma keep it a band
like [ __ ] it sound crazy but when you
wait
and then she give it to you and then
it's crazy you'll be like oh
i think i love a little bit i must stay
a little longer and he already been in
three months so this
is those two is in that three months you
guys [ __ ] with each other for
everything else besides the sex besides
and then if the sex is fired that means
like oh [ __ ] you got a homie and you've
been married now yeah bro it worked out
so well we watch movies together [ __ ]
the smoke weed now we where's my
[ __ ] dog bro
she be on the road with you and [ __ ]
moving around with you the only time she
stay home though because when we like
all right love we've been with my kids
for two kids too long
somebody has to be there to let them
know that they're still our kids
right right right right right and that's
the only time if that's not the case she
with me
no [ __ ]